[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC] JOSEPH
BETANCOURT: How does your
organization address racial equity
and access to health care delivery?
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: For decades, researchers
have studied the differences in quality of
care between people of color and their white
counterparts. They lead to poorer health
outcomes and exemplify low-value health care.
Together with the Disparity . Solution Center
at Massachusetts General Hospital, this course
uses case studies and insights from leaders
so you can create strategic approaches
that you can apply to your organization.
ALVIN POWELL: The history is the
reason for the disparities. There's
no other reason for the disparities
other than our American history.
MITCHELL KELLAWAY: There can be this sense that
we're doing everything right, so all of the
disparity is somewhere out there. But we need to
be really honest with ourselves when it's at home.
ALTAF SAADI: And a really important part
of implementing any policy or action at
your organization or health care facility
is understanding that it's a
process. It doesn't happen overnight.
ALVIN POWELL: It's the systemic and
structural racism that has existed for all
of these years that has created these significant
disparities that we continue to deal with today.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: To really
drive organizational change,
we have to include people from the top of
our organization all the way to the bottom.
JOSEPH BETANCOURT: Learn how to lead your
health care organization in tackling these
systemic problems and improving patient equity
with reducing racial disparities in health care.
[Music]